Hey there trendy 30-something
Silicon Valley resident,
what you working on?
Oh, a new app idea for mobile.
That's pretty cool.
So you've got your
venture capital ready?
Good, good.
Fancy designer and website?
Great.
Man, I can't wait to see how
your collaborative intelligent
algorithm helps users
find-- oh, you're not,
you're not doing any of that.
Oh well, you know I bet you've
got a really cool compression
algorithm.
I mean, reducing your
data transfer sizes
to third world country-- no?
Not doing that either, huh?
Well, I mean are you doing
anything with data compression?
I mean, that's kind
of important today.
No, nothing huh?
Well, hey listen.
Don't get down on yourself.
Come on, it's not that bad.
I mean you can still fix it.
All you need to do
is take your recipe
and sprinkle on a little
bit of Markov chains
and you'll be compressing
data in no time.
Well, you know Markov chains.
The mathematical
system that undergoes
transitions from one state to
another state on a state space
and is generally
characterized as memory-less.
Such that the state depends
only on the current state
and not that of the
sequence of events
preceding it, providing
that applications follow
statistical models of
real world processes.
No?
Nothing still?
You know what?
Maybe we should start
from the beginning.
But fret not, young
Silicon Valley hipster.
I'm here to help.
My name is Colt McAnlis and
this is Compressor Head.
[THEME MUSIC]
Teleprompter activate.
[LAUGHTER]
Now one of my favorite
pastimes is actually
taking great American
traditions and distilling them
into their state
graph counterparts.
Take example, baseball.
Although it may seem like
a bunch of random actions
to have one team win
or the other one lose,
there's actually a
very simple graph.
Let's just look at a
batter coming up to base.
So the batter comes
up to hit here.
And there's really
only two states.
Number one, he can actually
be out by hitting the ball
or striking out or
some other force of it.
Or he can actually get on base.
Now what the interesting
part about this
is that once you've move
to either the on-base state
or the out state, you
actually return back
and another batter
comes up to bat.
The cool thing about
this is that it's
pretty self-explanatory, right?
Only three states and a couple
transitions between them.
Now what if we actually want
to transmit some movement
through this graph to
another individual?
Say for example, we have
batter up, batter out, up,
and then they get on base.
Get up again and then
another batter out.
Well the simplest thing to do
that we've been doing so far
is assume that each
state is a finite symbol.
And we can encode each
one with about two bits.
Which means here we've
got one, two, three, four,
five six, at two
bits per-- means
if we want to send
this to somebody,
it'll be about 12 bits
for the entire stream.
However when we
look at this, there
may be a better way to do it.
Now what if instead of
assigning a variable bit lengths
to each of its
states, we instead
actually assign bit codes to the
transition between the states.
So for example, we put a zero
here, one here, zero here,
and a zero here.
Effectively, this allows us
to encode the transitions
between the states
very differently,
as long as the encoder and
decoder know the states
and how we're
moving between them.
Now if you take
this set up here,
that means that we're
actually encoding
these green arrows in our state.
And this allows us to
encode the entire stream
in five bits, which
is pretty good.
But I think we can do better.
If you look at our
graph here, there's
some implicit rules
about baseball
that we know to be true,
that we don't actually
have to encode in our graph.
For example, when a batter
is either out or on base,
we know that another
batter is going
to come up no matter what.
So we actually don't need to
encode this in our stream.
So we can get rid of
this and get rid of this.
Which means that the only
information we really
need to encode is
whether or not when
a better comes up, if they
end up out or on base.
This information allows us to
encode all of our symbol data
here in actually
only three bits.
So moving from 12 bits to 3 bits
is actually pretty important.
And what we've described
here-- the ability
to encode transitions
rather than the exact states
and then having some
of the transitions
be implicit in the
encoder and decoder
is actually the basis of
how Markov encoding works.
But of course, this
is a simple example
and it gets a little bit
more tricky than this.
In 1913, A.A. Markov found a
new branch of probability theory
by combining
mathematics and poetry.
Effectively delving into the
text of an Alexander Pushkin
novel, Markov
spend hours sifting
through patterns of
vowels and consonants.
And on January 23,
1913 publishers
were detailing a statistical
model that given a letter,
it was a finite and reproducible
probability associated
with what letter would follow.
You see by most accounts,
Markov was a pretty meddlesome
character, constantly
involved with political feuds,
public protests.
He was fiercely competitive
with any rivals in his field
and actually spend a
lot of time in jail
for massive rounds
of fisticuffs.
How fitting is that the
inventor of the algorithm,
which is powering most
of modern Silicon Valley,
was a rebel without a cause.
You see, Markov's concept o of
probabilistic events selection
was massively contrary to
the world of statistics
at the time, which mostly
involves modeling count
flipping and dice rolling.
You see at its
core, Markov chains
help us answer questions
about associative probability.
For example, if
it's cloudy today
what are the chances
that it's going
to rain two days from now?
A concept, which in 1913, was
as predictable with mathematics
as casting chicken bones.
Think about that.
Today Markov chains power some
of the biggest and most complex
big data algorithms
in Silicon Valley.
They're seen everywhere
from cancer research
to weather prediction to
modeling consumer behavior
and even figuring out
what the best pizza
joint is in San Jose.
The best part is, we can use the
same exact base algorithm that
powers all these big things
and use it for compression.
Let's take a look.
Channeling Markov's work,
we can encode a given string
by looking at a letter
and noting the transition
to the following letter.
Now for the sake of
simplicity here, I'm
going to redraw the
symbol pair transitions
as a tree with the first
letter in each pair
resides the head of tree
and the second pair resides
as the child node.
To give us some better
terminology in this topic,
we denote each pair in the
context as a zero based order.
That is the first letter
of the pairs context zero,
well the subsequent
letters are context one.
Now some of you graph purist
may be looking at this graph
and asking why T and
N don't both point
to O node as a child
of context one.
It is true that for both of
these context zero symbols,
O does follow as context one.
But it's actually
wrong to do that.
Here's why.
To understand why, let's
re-encode the string
with three simple steps, also
known as second-order context.
And use your concept of
sharing the context one state.
Now while this tree may look
visually stunning and very
pleasing it's actually quite
inaccurate with respect
to how the string
is constructed.
You see for example,
this graph will
allow you to move from T
through O in context one,
and then to T in context two,
introducing the string TOT,
which of course doesn't
exist in the input data.
This is of course an incorrect
to the proper thing to do.
And the proper thing to do is
only chart context transition
as unshared links.
Now let's extend the
concept forward a bit
and take a look at a
longer string using
first-order contexts,
that is two symbol pairs.
You can see that
a more real life
example changes our
distribution and gives us
a different sort of tree for
encoding with slightly more
complex state relationships,
with letters like T, O, and E
have multiple
potential transitions
to the next context.
If we wanted to
encode this example,
we would need some
way to assign bits
to each of the transitions
between the context.
The question, of
course, is how many
bits to assign to a transition,
which we can determine
as the max number of transitions
from a node in the entire set.
In this case, the O
node in context zero
has three transitions,
which means
we can use 2 bits
for everything.
Of course, this
is a bit wasteful.
For example, states
with only one transition
shouldn't need 2 bits.
Plus, we need to keep
around some number per node
to let the decoder know
how many bits to read.
And what happens if there's
16 transitions per node
instead of just 2?
The correct answer here is
to use variable length codes
to describe transitions.
This way, code words used
to describe these transition
can be variable
in size and it can
scale based upon
what's actually needed.
But remember, VLCs
only work if you
assign the most probable
symbol the smallest code word.
So in order to get the most
efficient compression possible,
we need to take
probability into account
when assigning code
words, which thankfully
is easy to do given the way we
actually construct our chains.
Doing so allows us to properly
use VLCs to encode our data.
And note one of the trickier
parts about our scheme
is that each context
transition-- that
is to say zero to each of
its children in context one--
manage its own
probability table.
And as such, has
its own VLC set.
To be clear, you're not
creating a VLC distribution
across the entire graph.
No, no.
That would be madness.
Recent years have
seen the construction
of truly enormous Markov chains.
For example, page
rank algorithm devised
by Larry Page and Sergey
Brin, the founders of Google,
is based on a Markov
chain whose states are
the pages of the world wide
web, perhaps 40 billion of them.
The transitions
between the states
are actually links
between the pages.
The aim of the algorithm is
to calculate for each page
the probability that a
reader following a link
will randomly arrive
at some further page.
Now in order to make Markov
practical for compression,
we need to take a more
technical look at the problem.
Now when it comes
to Markov chains,
theory and practical
implementations
are night and day different.
Sadly though this
isn't something
I can just talk about.
No, we're actually going to
have to get our hands dirty
and encode some things to
figure out what's going on.
As efficient as Markov
is for compression,
it comes with one huge flaw.
Let's say you want to transmit
this encoding to the decoder.
Well for each context
transition or a parent
to child transition, you'll
need to store a frequency
table-- that is the symbol and
its frequency of incurrence.
This data, of course,
would need to be
listed in the compressed streams
so the decoder could properly
decode this information.
But even for this
simple example,
the overhead of this
process is extreme.
Just as for all of this
frequency data, such
that the decoder
can properly work,
we would need 53
bytes to this stream.
The original stream
is only 22 bytes,
so obviously this
is not helping.
And it gets even worse
the larger our data set is
or the more context
we decide to keep.
The point here is that we can't
simply transmit our percentages
from the encoder to the
decoder using the data stream.
Instead we need to make
the whole thing work
as the decoder will generate
the same statistical properties
that the encoder is
using for the data,
as it's decoding the stream.
Let's say we wanted
to decode this stream,
dynamically generate
our probabilities,
and Markov chain encode
it all at the same time.
We start out with a completely
empty Markov data set.
When we read the first letter,
A, from the input stream,
we need to encode it.
But we can't because there's
no data so far to use.
As such, we need to
start creating our tree.
Once the trees is
created, we need
to encode A with a
variable length code
but we can't yet
because we first
need to assign it a probability.
Since this is the first
character we've seen,
we can give it a
probability of 100%.
Once we have our probability,
we can generate a Huffman tree,
which will let us assign
a code word to the symbol
A. Since we've got
nothing else in the tree,
it gets the code word 0.
Once we go to read
our second letter, B,
we also haven't seen it before.
So we need to add it as a
symbol and its probability
to our tree.
We also at this point need
to update our probability
for all the symbols
in this context.
Note that we've seen
a second B, which
updates its probability
in the table
and swaps its code word with A,
which is exactly what we wanted
since we're updating
probabilities
dynamically and generating
variable length codes based
on that.
The best part is
that we don't need
to transmit the probabilities
to the stream, just
the encoded bits.
However when we
try to decode this,
we run into a large
problem, namely
that we have no information
about the literals
or the probability table that
was used to construct this bit
stream, which basically means
the decoder can't actually
decode the stream and this
is an incorrect encoding.
To fix this, we're
actually going
to have to revisit our
encoder and figure out
a proper way to output
literals so the decoder can
consume them and reconstruct
the original stream.
Once we add A to the
tree for the first time,
we need some way of providing
it to the output encoded stream
so that the decoder can get it.
To do this, we add a
second output stream
called the literal stream, which
only contains 8 bits per symbol
characters that we
haven't actually seen yet.
We now need to tell
the output stream
when it should read the explicit
symbol from the literal stream,
rather than expecting
a variable length code.
To do this, we introduced the
concept of an escape code.
An escape code is
a special symbol
that we're going to use in
our probability table that
allows the decoder
to know when to read
a full literal from
our literal stream.
Now an escape code is
not a symbol in the sense
that A, B, or C is
but it does have
residency in our
probability table.
So it will get a variable
length code in the encoding.
Rather than starting
off with a blank tree,
any new context nodes
that are instead
initialized with an escape code
and set to 100% probability.
When we read the letter
A from the symbol stream,
we add it to the context,
update our code words,
output an escape code to the bit
stream, and then the letter A
to the literal stream.
Reading the letter B
is the same process.
We haven't seen it before.
So we output the code
word for an escape code
and then a literal value.
This is where the fun really
starts to happen, kids.
Once we read the next B,
it's not a new symbol.
We've actually seen it before.
As such, it's
critically important
to note that when we're
encoding an existing symbol
that we output the
variable length code
before updating our stats
and table code words.
Once we update the probabilities
of the table with the second B,
the weights change the
code word assignment.
As such, the decoder wouldn't be
able to see this type of change
and it would break things.
Decoding works the
exact same way.
Except when we encounter an
escape code, it tells us to go
read a symbol off the
literal stream and output it.
First we employ the process
of reading variable length
code from the bit stream.
If you're not familiar with
that, go check out Episode One.
Since the only value we
have is an escape code,
we simply need to read a
single bit from the stream
and find that we're
using an escape code.
This tells us to go
ahead and read 8 bits
from the literal stream,
push it to the output stream,
and update our
probability tables.
We read the next zero
from the bit stream
and seeing that it's
a variable length code
as well, we know to
read the next literal,
output it, and update
the probability tables.
At this point, we have
enough table information
that the next 2 bits
read off the bit stream
match with the letter B, which
of course we happily output.
We've read A from
the input stream
and realized it's in the table.
We've output our codes
to the output bit stream
and updated our probabilities.
But because we're
supporting context
we need to actually create
a new branch in the tree.
In the naive solution, each
symbol at each context level
would contain a pointer to its
children in the next context.
But in order to make
things work right,
we have to start all subsequent
context with an escape code.
So the good news is
that's the basics.
However, the bad news
is that we actually
need to support a
multi-context chain in order
to get proper and
legitimate compression.
And in order to
support that, we're
going to revisit the
encoder again and change
how a few things work.
Since we've just seen a new
symbol at this context level
that we haven't
seen before, we need
to start our chain back
over again at context zero.
Each time we read a
symbol in context zero
that already exists
in the context,
we move forward to read
the next symbol operating
in the subsequent context.
So if the first two
symbols were A, C,
we would find the
letter A and then add
C to the first-order
context set for encoding.
And to be clear we
treat a new symbol
at any context as a
completely new symbol.
So if we encounter the series
A, B, C in this encoding it's
the first time that we've
seen the letter C in context
to following B.
So we treat it the same way
as we would with context
zero by outputting it
to the literal stream
and emitting an escape code.
Once this is
entirely encoded, we
take our final bit
stream and literal stream
and pass it along to whatever
person on the internet
wants it, without having to
keep a single probability
table around at all.
In this solution
the original stream
was 88 bits while the encoded
stream is only 46 bits,
almost 50% reduction
which isn't bad.
So it should be really
obvious at this point
that efficient encoding
of Markov chains
has to strike a unique
balance between the length
of the chains that you
need for compression
and the available memory
that you have on the system
itself that you're
running the encoder on.
If you run out of
memory early then
it's not necessarily
a good thing.
A real encoder
strike this balance
with all separate profiles
of system analysis memory
and also writing
additional context to disk
to find the optimal solution.
Now hopefully one
of the questions
you're asking
yourself here is how
do we properly adjusted the
probability of an escape code
when new symbols are added?
In our little
examples we did here,
we simply subtracted
hundredth of a point from it.
But in reality it's
not that simple.
Unfortunately that's an
entirely separate show
that we're not going
to cover today.
In the mean time, Google it.
Now some people
view Markov chains
as a step in an
inevitable future
where artificial
intelligence algorithms
run the entire gamut
of data compression.
And that's pretty easy to see.
You see, keeping a
multi-level context is
much like tuning
a neural network
algorithm for
artificial intelligence.
Of course, we know by now those
most successful Markov chains
are actually terabytes
of relational data
long with thousands
of context in two.
Now lighter weight
versions of Markov chains
are already available
today in modern compressors
like 7-zip L pack and ZPack.
It's easy to see a
future down the road
where artificial intelligence
and cloud computing come
together in some weird hybrid
to create a revolution of data
compression that we haven't
seen it over 40 years.
But that is a topic
for a different show.
My name is Colt McAnlis and
this is Compressor Head.
[THEME MUSIC]